Tougher question. What time are we at? 50 something. Okay.
Barbary con.
Loco.
This is from our friend. Jago. My name is Jago.
I'm a big fan of the show and you guys are awesome. Here's my situation.
I'm currently in a long distance relationship.
My girlfriend lives in Brazil and I live in the U S we love each other very much
and want to stay together.
Even though sometimes it can be pretty hard because of the distance we see each
other every four months, either she comes to the U S or I go to Brazil.
She plans in, uh, on moving here sometime in the future.
We both are musicians and we're trying to start a music career. Anyway.
I wanted to know if you guys,
if you guys think it's a good idea for us to stay together,
and what are your opinions on long distance relationship?
I've been in several long distance relationships. Uh, three,
they don't work for actually. Okay. Um,
it only will work if there is an end goal.
If you set a date that by September of 2018,
we're going to be together. These are our plans.
If there's an actual plan rolled out,
if I can envision what these two years are going to look like,
then I can really invest in it.
But the reason that my previous ones didn't fail because I dated the
guy in Spain, I would see him once every four months. Same thing. There was no,
he wasn't going to move out here. I wasn't going to move out there.
We liked each other a lot, but at the end of the day, you know, I was still,
you know, in nursing school, I was like, look,
my job's going to be here and you play football.
And so there's no end goal there. And,
but, um, but I mean, I've seen it, you know,
definitely worked for some other people around me.
And that's only because the missing ingredient was, you know, the end date.
When are we going to beat together and set a goal?
That's a good one end date. All right, your turn, sir.
How many relationships have you been in long distance?
Me tell you something right now, my friend. Okay.
The reason why you're in the thing in the first place I'm talking to this guy.
I love you. Thanks for listening to tiger belly. Is, is that this,
the fantasy of her living over there? No, he lives there. I think. Well,
whatever, regardless, it's a goods or a part for different countries.
There is an element of mystery and a fantasy quality to what she lives in
Brazil. He's in us. Right? Okay. So he's like, Oh my God, what, what? You know,
but if you saw each other every day in the same house, right?
It changes the dynamic. You don't, you're not gonna feel the same way you do.
Right. It's kind of like unrequited love in that way where it's like,
there's a fantasy quality to fantasy. Yeah.
There is. I will give Bobby back.
You see him every day, like her and I, right. I feel so bad for her.
She has to see this. I mean, you don't even know what you, what? I don't,
I haven't washed my hair in what, five weeks. Really? Yeah.
I have foot fungus. It's crazy. Now I gotta put it down.
I have massive flipbook, fungus. You know what I mean?
I'm a disgusting fat slob. And she has to,
and I have the worst character defects and she has to deal with so much.
I'm so sorry, sweetie. But, but you,
don't why I know it's love because she's still in it. Yeah.
And know we're in it. You know what I mean? And I see some of her things,
she had a puffy lips the other day. It was kind of weird.
She gets to these weird zits to these weird zits. Right? Sometimes you,
her principal's a complete salmon.
Faster. She probably spilled seven after I, I,
I tell him I just ate salmon. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. He goes, where's those breasts. And then it's like summer,
but some of our health issues, you know, I mean, that's some, you know,
the ambulance comes. Yeah. These are all things that are part of a relationship.
And that's how, I'm how I know. I love her. Okay. We're in the thick of it.
When pick of it.
The, the beauty and the reason why I,
I even romanticize my previous relationships that were long distance,
because there is an element of me going to see him in Spain. Oh,
us always spending these three weeks. It felt like a vacation. Yeah.
There was no read. There was a real life aspects of talking about money.
There were no real life aspects of who's going to take the dog out for a.
It was always of, Ooh, I'm in the North of Spain and we're going hiking.
We're taking picnics and you know, we're having sex out and you know, it's like,
it's so fantastic. But yeah.
But, um,
I still think that if you have legitimate feelings for each other,
you should give it a shot, but you should give it a shot in the same place.
At some point.
They won't work out. All I'm saying is, is that, that whole fantasy thing.
But that's why it lasts so long. And this is always my thing. You know,
I have a friend, we have a friend in common. She's like, yeah,
I've been with this guy for three and a half years. It's like, well,
accumulated,
you've actually only been with him for four months because that's how much time
you've actually spent together in the, in the, in the three and a half years.
So how well do you really know him?
He ended up cheating on her with like multiple women.
B ended up being a really dude. She was like, I can't believe he did this.
I'm like, I can, you didn't know him.
You didn't know him in his day in and day out.
You didn't know what the he smelled. Like from Monday to Monday,
you didn't know the color of his fungus. You didn't know, you know,
the taste of his sweat on a on the fifth day that he didn't shower.
Like you don't know him. I'm talking about you. He's like, wait,
this sounds like it's it's it's so it's, it's not,
you have to think of it in terms of, you know, I know there's, you know,
gadgets these days, it's always so much, you know, FaceTime.
You can talk to each other while you take a or whatever.
It's just not the same to be physically in the room with someone is a little bit
different than it kills the romance. It really does.
We've become so functional. Bobby and I, that we're trying, we talk about like,
how do we reignite the feeling of like having
butterflies in your stomach? Cause, I mean, we don't feel that for each other.
This is functional. It works. We're a team. We're the best.
I don't know. I don't know. I just,
the longest relationship I've ever been in and I'm just learning.